we're so excited it's a little crazy to
testament to NBC's confidence in us not
only is the Will & Grace revival
happening it's already been renewed for
a second season can you tell me about
this without screeching like a howler
monkey et spoke with the cast of the NBC
TC a press event on Thursday when we
last saw Will & Grace we had a little
bit of a time jump in the finale they
had kids they had a fight are we just
gonna be erasing that what's going on we
did an age makeup to be this age and
when they realize that that's not how we
look that we actually aged a little
better than our makeup we don't have to
jump so far and make such bold decisions
I think we realized that when we ran our
funniest and our loosest was before all
those commitments and so we're creating
a very quick reason that none of those
is Karen on a stage of Bieber Heusen
when we see her again well all I can say
is my first line is I had the craziest
dream friends with Johnny and Milania
[Music]
Jack will be teaching a class and he has
branded a new style of acting called
Jack thing so you'll see that grace to
him when we pick up what's she up to she
is doing incredibly well in her
professional life she really has just
advanced a lot and she is single and for
reasons that will be explained Will and
Grace are living together once again
this show really pushed the envelope 11
years ago as to what we could see on
broadcast TV how much edgy are we gonna
see it now that it's on in 2017 the
society we live in is never-ending with
social issues and problems that we will
tackle now so these characters will
exist in 2017 and deal with the issues
everybody's talking about the easiest
and most challenging part stepping back
into their shoes the most challenging
part at my age is sitcom lighting I'm
not I'm scared about that
the easiest part always is the four of
us together
[Music]
Oh